all right so let me talk about something
green that is coming to New York City
nope
dispensary is set to open in New York
today it's called Housing Works cannabis
company it is in lower Manhattan and
it's one of the first to get its
dispensary retail license it's operated
by the non-profit Housing Works known
for helping the homeless and the
formerly incarcerated and also people
living with HIV and AIDS adults age 21
and older will be able to buy legally
recreational marijuana in New York when
the store opens at get this what time do
you think it opens
[Laughter]
just kidding that one I know
I was literally gonna be like really
Adriana I was gonna say hi noon
got the jokes today uh New York state
has approved 36 cannabis dispensary
licenses it's going to be lucrative big
business Canada who's going well
everybody's like uh don't be shy I know
everybody's like turning around they're
all shy
I'll see you there no I'm only kidding I
will not see you there no no no
no
[Laughter]